What do you call cheese that’s not yours?
Nacho cheese!
Did you just smile or laugh out loud?
Turns out it could depend a lot on your genes.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
How happy of a person you are depends on a
lot.
Your personality, your circumstances, and
even your culture can all impact your happiness.
And some people are happier than others.
Some people when they hear a stupid pun or
a good joke will crack a small smile while
others will throw their heads back in a belly
laugh.
Research published in the American Psychological
Association journal Emotion found that there’s
a link between your genes and how emotionally
reactive you are.
The researchers looked at short and long alleles
of the gene 5-HTTLPR, which might be responsible
for some of the activity of the neurotransmitter
serotonin.
Most people think that serotonin plays a part
in mood disorders like depression and anxiety.
Previous research suggests that those with
the short allele are more prone to negative
mood disorders like depression.
But this new research finds that it’s not
all bad news for short allele havers.
Turns out those with the short allele are
also more likely to laugh and smile more at
funny things.
So maybe this gene kind of acts as an amplifier
for emotion.
People with the short allele might be more
emotionally reactive to their environments.
So negative experiences hurt more, but they
also thrive in positive environments.
Other studies like one published in the journal
Psychological Science, also found evidence
of a genetic predisposition to happiness.
In this study researchers studied more than
900 pairs of twins.
Twins are often used in studies that look
for genetic links.
The researchers found that those who “do
not excessively worry, and who are sociable
and conscientious tend to be happier”.
And that these traits might be genetic to
some degree.
This personality can even act as a buffer
during more difficult periods of that persons
life.
But if you’re worried you don’t have the
right inherited traits, the researchers stress
that only 50% of your happiness is dependant
on your genes.
Your relationships, health and careers easily
make up for the other half.
On the other hand, being happy can impact
your genes!
One study published in the journal Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences found
that different types of happiness can change
your gene expression.
Even though they had similar rates of happiness,
people’s gene expression looked different
based on what kind of happiness that was.
People who rate highly on eudaimonic well-being
or happiness, that’s like having a sense
of purpose and meaning in life, have low levels
of inflammatory gene expressions and strong
expression of antiviral and antibody genes.
And conversely, those with hedonic well-being,
like consuming things to gain happiness, have
high levels of inflammatory gene expressions
and lower antiviral and antibody gene expression.
Which would, you know, change how your immune
system responds to an infection.
So don’t worry, be happy!
Real happiness, not the kind of happiness
our consumeristic society wants you to have.
Your genes will thank you.
And if you’re happy, maybe you should thank
your genes!
On a related note, do you ever cry when you’re
happy?
Why do you do that?
Tara has some answers in this video